oh la la qu'est-ce qui fait chaud mais
la longue dans mon jardin je n'arrête
pas de transpirer pas vous et en plus je
suis rouge écarlate pire qui après un
marathon
allez on bouge on va se mettre au frais
dans l'atelier et faut pas rester ici il
fait trop chaud
[Musique]
l'homme est au mais au terme ce qui
signifie que notre température interne
reste toujours la même
aux alentours de 37 degrés c'est pour
cette raison que l'hiver nous
frissonnons quand notre température
descend en dessous de 37 degrés c
frissonnement se traduisent par la
contraction des muscles ce mouvement
génère de la chaleur qui fait remonter
notre température interne ça arrive
aussi l'été quand on glisse un glaçon
dans le coup par exemple
[Musique]
c'est froid l'été quand il fait chaud et
que notre température interne grimpe
nous transpirons ce qui permet d'évacuer
la chaleur et de revenir 37 de grippe
pourquoi 37 vous savez notre organisme
est constitué de cellules des centaines
de milliards qui fonctionne comme autant
de petites usines
elle transforme les aliments produisent
des protéines fabrique de l'énergie
comme le moteur d'une voiture
elles sont performantes à une certaine
température en l'occurrence 37 degrés en
dessous ou au dessus
elles ne fonctionnent pas correctement
de l'organisme en souffrent ça va ça
chauffe pas trop alors poursuivre quand
il fait chaud justement nous transpirons
mais attention ce n'est pas parce que la
sueur est froide qu'elle nous rafraîchit
elle est à la même température que notre
corps
d'abord qui ouvre les vannes
alors nous sommes équipés d'un
thermostat situé au coeur du cerveau si
si c'est un cerveau dans l'hypothalamus
dès que la température franchi la barre
des 37 degrés le cerveau envoie un
signal qui déclenche la dilatation des
vaisseaux sanguins
c'est pour cette raison que tout à
l'heure j'étais tout rouge
en se dilatant les vaisseaux sanguins
augmentent leur surface des changes avec
l'extérieur ce qui leur permet d'évacuer
plus facilement la chaleur parallèlement
les glandes sudoripares situé dans le
derme se remplissent d'eau qu'elle pompe
dans nos tissus et l l'évacuent vers
l'extérieur la sphère sort par les ports
vous savez ces petits trous disséminés à
la surface de la peau comme je l'aï dit
tout à l'heure
cette sphère est à la même température
que les tissus doux ensor alors comment
fait-elle pour refroidir la sueur est
essentiellement constituée d'eau liquide
des molécule h2o qui s'attire les unes
les autres
un peu comme des aimants une fois sur la
peau elle s'évapore très concrètement
les molécules se détachent les unes des
autres
l'eau passe de l'état liquide à l'état
gazeux et pour cela les molécules ont
besoin d'énergie elle capte de la
chaleur dans nos tissus qui
refroidissent ce n'est donc pas la
transpiration qui nous fait refroidir
mais l'évaporation de la sueur et c'est
d'ailleurs pour cette raison que nous
frissonnons quand nous sortons de la
douche
l'eau qui ruisselle sur notre corps
n'est pas froide au contraire mais elle
puise de la chaleur dans nos tissus pour
s'évaporer et du coup on frissonne même
chose avec une bombe aérosol nono
rafraîchi parce qu'elles puisent de la
chaleur dans nos tissus pour s'évaporer
c'est clair bah vous avez la chance
parce que moi je vois plus rien du tout
en tout cas je me sens mieux
enfin façon de parler parce que question
odeurs la transpiration sais pas ce qui
se fait de mieux en fait ce n'est pas la
sueur qui sont mauvais c'est sa
dégradation surtout celle qui est
produite au niveau des aisselles elle
contient des nutriments dont raffolent
les bactéries qui se développent à la
surface de la peau à cet endroit
eh bien elles ont dû faire un festin
tête aller prendre une douche main
ah j'oubliais en temps normal nous
produisons un litre de sueur par jour
mais quand il fait très chaud comme
aujourd'hui où quand nous faisons du
sport ça peut aller jusqu'à 8 litres de
l'eau qu'il faut absolument renouveler
si on veut être en capacité de refroidir
notre organisme et je ne compte pas tout
look nous évacuerons en parlant ou en
urinant aller à la vôtre est maintenant
à la douche
sinon j'aime prendre un savon dans la
petite caméra nous produisons en moyenne
1 litre de sueur par jour n'ont en
moyenne qu'en temps normal à jouer j'ai
senti comme un nom la sueur et x non
c'était l'autre côté